So, a while ago, I put out a video called "I'm going on antidepressants"
and... the reception was very weird from my friends,
Any happiness that you feel on it is going to be fake happiness.
You can only find real happiness...
inside of yourself.
My family,
Honey, mental illness is just an illness...
in your mental.
The internet,
I exercise regularly,
eat predominantly vegan and macrobiotic meals,
drink plently of water and green tea,
I take vitamins,
I get enough sleep,
and I plan out enough time to relax and unwind.
And meds didn't cure my depression,
they just kind of raised the floor of it.
So that the bottom wasn't so far down.
So, I started taking ten milligrams of Lexapro about three months ago,
and I noticed a difference right away...
and so did my boyfriend, I was like, "hey, did you- have you noticed any difference?"
and he was like, "yes!"
But, uh, about a week in, I remember I was doing a standup show
and I almost always do a meet and greet afterwards
and... there was this long line, and I was getting through it,
when this lady came up to me and shouted in front of everybody
that she felt ripped off and cheated because she didn't think I did enough time onstage to make it worth her while.
Now, my normal reaction to something like that
would be to cry, of course, you know
from like, the shame and the humiliation and the- and being sad that I disappointed her
But there was this moment where my brain kinda paused and was like,
"well, there's 250 people in line who clearly liked the show and no one else has said anything,
are you going to let yourself cry over one lady's opinion?"
And I realized in that moment, like,
oh my god, my whole life my emotions have been so extreme,
they're always a rollercoaster,
and it was the first moment of emotional clarity I had that...
I don't have to... cry.
The first four to six weeks were really rough,
the primary side effect I experienced was just tiredness, just being very tired all the time.
In a way it was great because I just read a lot of books
I was like, "oh, I'm too tired to actually work, I'm just gonna lay down and read."
But then I would get exhausted the moment I started working out,
and I'd always want to take a nap,
or I'd oversleep.
So, I've started taking my meds in the evening
and I can report that it is... so much better.
I don't know if I'll go off of them anytime soon.
I really love this- this feeling of just stability that I have, you know?
I'm so used to being like this and being sad or really happy or really angry about everything
and I still get sad, you know, I still cry when it's appropriate
and I still get angry about a lot of things
and I'm still very- very happy, I'm actually more happy than I was prior to meds.
Um, but I have also heard stories from friends who had terrible experiences with antidepressants
and... they didn't want to stay on them because it made them feel weird.
So I think this whole experience has kind of taught me that there is no right answer and there is no cure,
I think ultimately, we just kind of have to find out what works for us.
And luckily for me, this is working for me right now.
That may change, of course,
but right now, I've found some help.
And I'm not ashamed of it.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome, Gotham.